traditional Maya weaving techniques are  being preserved in the gorgeous lakeside  village of San Juan La Laguna in  Guatemala founded in 1996 Casa  Florrick's cocoa was established to  preserve indigenous weaving styles that  were at risk of disappearing due to the  country's 36 year long civil war today  23 Weaver's are keeping maya art alive  using sustainable methods the  co-operative uses 100% organic cotton  grown in the mountains surrounding lake  atitlan local plants not chemicals  supply all the dye colors used in the  bold designs  after the cotton is processed into  vibrant bundles of yarn the weavers move  the backstrap leaving a loom that is  intrinsic to Maya culture it can take  months to complete the elaborate designs  that marry modern style with Maya  tradition visit the cooperative in San  Juan La Laguna or visit their online  store to support indigenous arts in  Guatemala  [Music]  [Music]